your live Channel
good evening and welcome to this Central
area planning committee uh meeting of
Malden District Council on Wednesday the
25th of January 2023. I am councilor
Carly Mays chairman of this committee
this meeting will be streamed live and
recorded by being present in the meeting
you are giving consent to being recorded
members and officers during each item
please indicate if you wish to speak I
will then invite you at the appropriate
time
I encourage all members to keep
contributions clear and concise please
when invited to speak please remain
seated and speak clearly remembering to
turn your microphone on and off
appropriately when speaking and
referring to agenda papers please ensure
you reference a page or paragraph number
can I have um
apologies please
thank you
item three it is recommended that the
minutes of the meeting of the central
area planning committee held on the 16th
of November 2022 are approved as a true
and accurate record these are presented
for accuracy only ISO move do I have a
seconder
thank you councilor none
are there any matters of accuracy that
we need to raise
can these be agreed by ascent
thank you members
Declarations of Interest members are
reminded that they are required to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests other
registerable interests and
non-registerable interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regards to paragraph 9 and appendix B of
the code of conduct for members
you are also reminded that you are
required to disclose any interest as
soon as they become aware should the
needs arise through the meeting do I
have any declarations councilor stilts
yes thank you I'd like to declare a
non-regitable uh interest in I know the
applicant and that I sit on another
committee with Mr Brown
thank you uh cancer if you want to see
uh thank you chair
um yes I also um non-pecuniary I also
know Mr Brown uh have had conversations
with him thank you thank you councilman
yes thank you chair I'm also acquainted
with the applicant and uh although it
was a very long time ago I went to
school there thank you
thank you members
um we now moved to item five
um application two two zero one zero
seven five All Saints School Highlands
Drive Malden on pages 13 to 20 in your
packs The Proposal is for a single story
front extension single story rear
extension internal Remodeling and
alteration Works to all skate All Saints
Church of England primary
the applicant is Mr Brown the agent is
Barker Associates the application has
come before us as the applicant is
related to a member of Malden District
Council staff
members you should have had a copy of
the presentation that was circulated I
think on Monday
um Miss Sadler could you present the
report please
German the application seeks permission
for a single story front and single
story rare extension which would infill
an area of existing hard standing to
both the front and the rear the
application site is located on the
western side of Highland Drive within
the settlement boundary of Morden the
site is occupied by single story Primary
School
this is the location plan
the block plan which shows the location
of the proposed rear and front
extensions
these are the existing and proposed
front Southeast elevations
which shows the proposed extension and
proposed fenestration alterations as
part of the extension to the front
this is the existed and proposed rear
elevations which shows the proposed rear
extension
the existing and proposed side Northeast
elevations which shows the proposed
extension to the front which will infill
an existing opening gap between a
storage building and the school and some
proposed fenestration alterations
this is the exist in a proposed
Southwest side elevations and there's no
changes to these elevations
this is the existing floor plan the
existing area of heart standing is
colored in red hatching
and the proposed this is the proposed
first floor plan and the proposal floor
plan sorry oops
and the front and rear extensions are
denoted by the grade area
is the existing front entrance facing
Northwest
side
this is the existing rear entrance space
in southeast
end of the presentation thank you
chairman
thank you
members uh I'm now going to open the
debate and I'm going to start with Ward
member councilor Nunn
thank you very much chairman um well
along with you as you know this is in
our award
um the site has been designated as a
School site since the 1970s it's a large
site
um these single story extensions
um as Mr Sadler said
um seem uh to be in Phil with no loss of
amenity site or playground
the design seems to be in keeping the
officers are recommending approval I'd
be happy to support that recommendation
subject to the conditions that have been
stated thank you very much
thank you councilor councilor Lagann
thank you very much chair
um I just don't if the proposal from
Council London which I'd be gladly
second but also a comment on the report
and the presentation very clear very
concise and very good report to make
people like myself understand what the
school's objectives actually are so I
just wanted to say thank you for that as
well thank you thank you it was nice and
clear
okay members uh we have a proposal
um to approve this application seconded
by councilor Lagan
um are can I have a show of hands for
all those in favor
one two three four five six seven eight
nine
are we uh
if you'd like to raise a question
counselor
um
uh how much of that is being in field to
presumably take Nova's classroom
um quite a large area
um at the expense of
um
well open area for
no if you could show that yesterday yes
of course so the area to the rear this
one so the
the extension will come in line with
this side of the building and come
across so you're just losing this um
Courtyard canopy Courtyard area where
the the back entrance of the school is
here when entering from the playground
there's a playground here and the
playground behind so just it's just
mainly This Grass area here
that will be in field
I don't think this is part of the this
it doesn't it doesn't come further than
this line of the building if I can go
back to the floor plan
oops it's a dead spice
it is a very dead space so okay um
counselor herd
um thank you well actually I was going
to recover your words it is they're both
dead spaces absolutely I think I think
the front will certainly be enhanced by
that in fact it's crying out to be
infilled
um and it's and I'm familiar with the
rear
um of the building because the
playground goes beyond beyond that
anyway so I'm not concerned about the
amount of amenity space
um I can remember when this school had a
number of demountables which were slowly
rotting away
um in the back there I'm very very
pleased to see this application come
forward so that the children and the
parents will have a school that they can
be proud of
um and I think certainly this
application enhances the building and
utilizes the space very sensibly so I'm
very supportive of it thank you Council
Shaughnessy
uh yes thank you chair
um four councilor Swain's benefit if I'm
a chair
um there is a huge uh play area left
lots of playgrounds based and indeed a
field
so there's still um plenty of um I mean
yeah thank you thank you does anybody
else wish to make a comment
I will go back to the proposal that
councilor Nunn put to agree this
proposal uh subject to the five
conditions
um that are listed in your papers and
seconded by councilor Lagan can I have a
show of hands for all those in favor one
two three four five six seven eight nine
10. thank you that is carried
we moved to item six items of business
the chairman has decided are Urgent
there are none
item seven members and officers thank
you very much for your contributions
this evening and thank you for those
that are watching on our streaming
services I now draw the meeting to a
close at
17 40.
that is the shortest meeting